I've been hearing the phrase resting
[ __ ] yes resting [ __ ] have you
heard of that end yeah I it's it's it's
when you know when your face is in a
neutral position that's when your face
looks mean or angry even if you don't
feel that way inside right resting
[ __ ] exactly some say Queen
Elizabeth has the perfect resting
[ __ ] I'm clearly online that's what
they're saying I think we have a picture
here there's Queen Elizabeth she's you
know and it's apparently it's not just
women guys can have resting [ __ ]
you check out Kanye okay that is an
advanced case of RBF what do you think
Andy well yeah I guess it's okay I mean
I like being snarky time to time but
this whole RBF thing feels like a little
bit like bullying I mean you're calling
people out on something that they can't
even really control I agree Andy plus
it's sexist you know sure get the Kanye
picture but resting [ __ ] has the
word [ __ ] in it and that implies it's
mostly women
that is telling women you'd be a lot
prettier if you smiled I mean if you
said that to a woman at work that would
be harassment but online it's okay
[Applause]
[Music]
the audience was just applauding that we
finally got a light on him hey thanks
for watching be sure to click subscribe
to see even more great Conan clips you
may now return to your pirated movies
and creepy Japanese pornography